you
[Music]
my name is Brian thank you Rick for
introducing me I've been doing data
engineering for about 10 years now
different industries
I contribute a little bit to hive back
in the day back when it was still M R
and a project called giraffe which many
of you probably haven't even heard of
but for now I work on the the artist
creators and tools team at Pandora so we
work with social media and the Pandora
data to try to create useful insights
for artists labels managers pretty much
everybody but the listeners so every day
we send the music labels a data set
containing song play Ament so what do I
mean by a song play a vent every time
somebody listens to a song on our
platform we report on that so we call
that a spin internally kind of makes
sense when you think about it but and
there's actually people from the labels
here and the data engineering teams that
receive that data so it's not expecting
that but the pressures on I guess so why
do we have to do this I mean the short
answer is we have to write okay but that
doesn't help why do we have to the long
answer so a bit of a history like
Pandora is got a reputation for a very
personalized music streaming service
right people like our recommenders but I
think the industry has proven out in the
last couple years especially that people
really want on-demand to like now that
that's possible and a lot of the legal
issues have been worked out and those
battles have been fought people like
that you know I don't even wager to
guess many people in this room probably
have a Spotify account or Apple music or
something other than Pandora even if
your app Android listener so they found
Pandora found that most of our users
were complimenting penned or with
something else and still do like they
hear a song they really like it and they
can't just listen to it again so even if
they're paying for it so they go to
youtube and they would look it up and
and we just didn't really want that so
now we actually have an on-demand
streaming tier there's different ways to
access it you can be a paying customer
and get access to that I won't go
through all that today but in terms of
actually so now that we support that we
have to report labels one reporting on
every single
in every single instance of the song
spinning for which they have rights do
so we have to send those datasets them
every day and it's not even a it's not
even a report per se like this song spun
X number of times they actually want a
structured event for each individual
spin event that happens so these get to
be big and we have to eat their external
data sets that were effectively
delivering over s3 every day and it's a
new requirement Pandora didn't always
have to do this we had kind of an
adversarial relationship with the labels
for years and that all had to change
very rapidly when we wanted to do
on-demand because they have the rights
that music so so what do these events
look like this is a very stripped-down
version there's about 20 22 different
structured fields but they go something
like this this kind of gets to the core
of it like what time did it play down to
the second right what's the name of the
track some others you could predict
right maybe the artists name I didn't
include here how long did the track play
when it's fun that's important and then
I one of the more interesting ones I
threw on here is the play source so that
gets that's a very complex field
internally that we managed how did the
user actually launch the song on the app
there's dozens of ways this can actually
happen maybe it was just a traditional
station spin from the recommenders maybe
it was they have like a premium playlist
and the playlist ended and so I
recommend errs kick in there too and
start it seeds everything off your
playlist and starts spitting out new
songs it just plays them or maybe they
were like a premium access thing where
they're not paying for it but they
wanted they were willing to listen to a
30-second video ad and then we give them
access to the song they search for that
ended up being wildly popular when we
launched that and so where does this
data come from big picture so there's
lots of Pandora's a huge hive shop we've
run all sorts of different Hortonworks
clusters completely isolated but not
totally firewalled off but the data that
we care about comes from one of our
primary analytics clusters so there's
there's a huge trough of partition spins
data all in Parque form that we generate
off of their raw data and then we have
metadata that we
build up to so I only included two
different tables here to show the
metadata but we consider all single
station ads every single station that a
user has as metadata across all our
users it's a big data set but we call it
metadata because relative to the spins
data and the the fact level data it's
not that big listener data and there's
others like artists track roles that
artists had in the track composers album
all of that stuff and listeners is an
important dimension to so that that
comes in every day from external sync
processes which my team doesn't have to
think about and we the whole pipeline
that I'll show is that we when we when
we detect that our transformation
succeeded on the island of cluster for a
given day and all this we just CP that
back to a private cluster that we can
control so we can rely on it to do this
reporting that we need to do and then
also I threw on here we do the Pandora
does we have Kafka queues where this
stuff all lives on to our our team has
not gone through the motions to actually
transform or update our report to
actually use that to do this reporting
just because we haven't gotten around to
it yet but we they do throw spins and
other things on the other metadata on
the Kafka queues we have we just our
team doesn't actually leverage that yet
but we plan to it would cut down the
latency so the first iteration of the
entire pipeline which I'll show in a
second it was pretty slow I mean it
would be to get data for like all the
spins that happened on a Tuesday over to
the labels would be take to like
Thursday and we just wanted to do better
than that so we wanted to improve the
overall latency of how we send these
files on s3 and to do that we took we
looked at two primary things one is the
obvious one it's like the runtime of
each individual step in the workflow how
could we improve that there were glaring
issues and then also the bigger one more
indirect was how do we recover from
issues that happen along each way like
if the disappea sales or something like
that we don't want to have to redo
upstream work and so we set out to break
out all those checkpoints
so there's you can see that I kind of
structured this whole presentation is
kind of like a war story form where I
actually cut out a lot of the like well
this is what we used to do and we didn't
like and I'm just going right to the
solution so I don't have a lot of like
before and after run times there's
plenty of time for questions I'm sure
some of that will come up but uh I don't
feel like it doesn't really help to brag
about those numbers either because it's
not that interesting to the people
outside the team but so what were issues
with the previous pipeline just just to
summarize we'll go we'll give it one
slide for that part
well there's upstream delays on the raw
data coming in to us we don't really
control a lot of the sync processes or
some of those other analytics teams and
what they do and and there's just a
natural delay because of how they're
working with daily partitions so some of
that's delayed and we just can't control
that but the data set generation RN once
we have it in that private cluster was
very slow and I won't get into a lot of
reasons why but it just was and so we
and then also part of our requirements
structure to the labels as we send a
single file per day and I've asked
around like why that is it just I just
accept that it is for now and so it's a
I know it's a bit of like a big data
anti-pattern right a lot of us we're
used to working with directories of
files or buckets of files that where all
the files represent everything in the
day and you get better parallelism that
way but we send a single file per day
for to each label for all the spins that
happen for tracks that they they have
rights to and then so part of the
problem was the steps two and three were
regenerated and we're making the single
file we're tightly coupled so any kind
of issues with either-or would scuttle
the entire thing
so the new pipeline follows kind of just
a series of linear steps upstream on the
analytics cluster we have we do some
transformations for both the raw and
metadata and I'll cover a little bit
more of that in detail like what that
means but we do that work directly on
the Pandora analytics clusters through
with high Montes so we we use it that
way once that data is prepared and those
partitions are active and we validated
them we just repeat that back to our
private cluster kind of in batch
and then once we detected the deceive
you the atomic deceive II is succeeded
we can begin building we use spark very
heavily on our team to generate this
data set is one of the uses for it was
one of our first uses of spark on our
team actually this delivery was so
important that we set out to we spark
was actually one of an early test cases
for it and then so once we have this
data set and the data set itself has
been validated we want to coalesce it
into a single file for the labels and
then we just have to push that up to s3
so in order to automate all this each we
kind of codify each level each step of
the workflow and then five point series
we use Python classes our team still
uses Luigi I know a lot of the mine
share in the data engineering space is
kind of moved over to air flow and other
frameworks are more popular but we still
really like Luigi on our team we feel
like it's lightweight and the visualizer
it works very well for us and I think
the most important part is the it force
when you define your tasks you it has a
contract where you really have to define
what it means for the task to be done
given parameters right it's not enough
in the past workflow tools that they
were considered done if it ran without
exception and that's really not good
enough anymore I'll get into kind of how
we we go around that and so the nice
thing too about a lot of these
frameworks are the supplies the workflow
and and kind of modeling your
dependencies in the dagger are
completely decoupled from what it's
actually doing to run it right we have
Scala SPARC jobs that run to CP Hadoop
commands that doesn't matter they're all
codified in Luigi and Python so these
Python the Luigi tasks form tags of
dependencies naturally when you wire
your requires in Luigi
we simply have parameters that we supply
on the command line where we launch
these and then the parameters that we're
necessary we propagate this down into
the requires dependency so I know some
of this is standard Luigi stuff for
people have used to used to working with
it most notable parameters are label so
when I say label I mean music label by
the way and then dates the date they're
active date that we're running out for
that label
and this lets us reuse certain tasks
across different labels and also where
tasks can be shared we just send the
date if there are not label specific
like the disk CP and then here's a
visualization of that graph kind of
rotated 90 degrees so that it can fit on
a PowerPoint slide left to right we're
trying to actually run the push tasks
that's what we actually launch we say
okay it's a new day push to s3 or cron
does and it's like well wait a minute
before I could do that I have to have a
single file okay well the single file
doesn't exist I need to generate it and
it just recursos all the way back until
it notices for the day that we're trying
to do that hasn't even transformed the
data yet and so in a bit more detail
each of these pipeline tasks we have to
do we have to code up our three things
all of which are mandatory right we have
to codify any dependencies it has what
what what upstream is necessary and we
need a function to evaluate when we're
done right we need a way to actually say
I have arrived at a state of
completeness and then most importantly
we need a function if it's not at that
state of completeness to generate some
artifact or external state so that it
now is at a state of completeness and
here's what some of the code looks like
this actually doesn't use the Luigi
parameter API just because it's I
thought it was easier to visualize it
here and just see it and rot by then but
the push task takes in a date and label
parameter because it's its label and
date specific and at first it requires
that there actually be a single file
that we've coalesced together with all
the data into it and so that requires
sending the date and label parameters
down the dag and do it and I kind of
commented or wrote comments for what the
run a complete would do right like the
run if there's not a single order of um
if it's not actually done yet
it means the runs gonna execute and we
just do the work of pushing that single
file up to an s3 bucket it's not
terribly complicated and then complete
this you might guess it's pretty
straightforward the push task is
complete if for a given label that
artifact exists already up in s3 for the
given date
and then here's how the labels are
here's how the parameters actually
propagate down the dag right the push
coalesced and generate stages are all
very label specific for the report we're
building but we can the dist CP and the
transform steps just need the date so
those get reused and so the scheduler
might be trying to kick this off
aggressively throughout the day maybe
the first attempt it gets it recurse is
down it sees the transform isn't done so
does that then disi piece exceeds but
then it gets to the point where it's
generated it's running the spark job and
let's say there's some errant error or
something some intermittent issue and it
fails right and we get some kind of
alert for that well we don't freak out
too much
the scheduler because this is all
scheduled to run automatically in cron
and we don't we don't run these by hand
the second Skaro temp for the day I can
pick up right where it left off because
the disk CP tasks do the work of
actually defining what it means for them
to be done right so the dag can kind of
reuse work from earlier executions
because it's just it just has functions
to kind of figure out where it was and
this is kind of the core the whole
presentation about how like we the
fault-tolerance helped with the overall
latency right like and you pass in teams
I've been on the past that a failure
like that would out you'd have to redo
everything maybe the disk CP would have
to be redone but yeah we can use the
scheduler to kind of aggressively work
off checkpoints and so this kind of
bottom-up execution pattern that
everyone's familiar with airflow in the
wedi it leads to not to checkpoint in
your work right it makes you it forces
you to think about what decoupling
points exist and where you can reuse and
where you can break off on and say at
least I'm done that for the day and you
can the most important thing is you can
schedule a daily tasks that you only
need to run once a day could be
scheduled to run even as aggressively as
every 10 minutes and that's how our
crontab we use we still use Chronos
still a little bit older but that's how
its set up as soon as the new day rolls
around cron is just an automatically
trying to do the latest the label
reports for that day but it can't it it
gets to a point where
because the data is not there yet but as
soon as it is available
it'll just launch I'll go through that
more we rely very heavily on the Luigi
scheduler to figure out what state the
pipeline is in right
is it ready to run is it not ready yet
because the data is not there yet
is it done already for the day we don't
want to redo it if it is so just to buy
just a simple thing is defining that
complete contract we get all this for
free which is the nice thing and that I
again it goes without saying if we're
gonna have a recursive bottom-up
pipeline like this we need a base case
for for defining this execution and in
our case like put in English our base
cases we need a way to detected the raw
data that we're transforming is
available on the base pend or analytic
clusters and our team my team in
particular has absolutely no control to
force that right we it's not as simple
as just writing a Luigi task and it'll
execute that those sources and all the
better completely outside our means in
our purview and we don't frankly want to
own that so we can just codify what it
means to have we can codify a task to
kind of check for us and then not blow
up if it's not ready but kind of
gracefully exit leaf nodes in the dag in
other words and this is our leaf node
per se we define it a little bit
differently than the traditional
external tasks for those familiar with
Luigi we use a bit of a different
pattern it takes in a date and a min ROS
parameter which is used for validation
it doesn't have any requirements it
doesn't require anything we're just
gonna run it right away it's not done
already and the job of it running is to
transform the events for the given day
in the form that we want the raw events
all the spins data and we look at
completeness as saying well we're gonna
do a count over that new partition and
if it's at least greater than some
threshold which we've we've done the
work offline to determine what what
makes sense then we'll know that it's
valid we'll know that it succeeded so
that does two if the partition failed to
generate the count will be zero if not
actually just blow up the query and even
if there's some kind of malformed issue
with the partition there's still this is
a very important defensive guard this
has saved us several times actually
since I've been on the team
where there was malformed data that came
in for whatever reason and I couldn't
even dream up and we just had these in
place and we've actually been in the
position of having to alert those teams
because of these these checks we can see
like okay something's wrong and we're
the ones to actually tell the team I'm
not trying to throw my other other teams
upend or under the bus but they have
pretty good alerting but this is act
that's actually happened where we were
just watching and noticed before them so
the task is done if it passes validation
of the Monroes check succeeds we're
pretty confident at that point and then
again you know these data delays happen
frequently it's not always their fault
they have complex syncs that have to
deal with this and they manage the kafka
rights now too so but we can use the
scheduler to not really care right we're
just going to aggressively schedule it
to run every X minutes
I think it's defined as like 30 minutes
in production for us and we supply the
current day we say oh every 30 minutes
just try to run this you know is it's in
human form it's like the I think about
is like from The Simpsons are we there
yet are we there yet
Homer Simpson always driving I didn't
put a meme up for that but I guess I
could have it's it's like but computers
don't mind being asked that right it's
annoying for us but we can just
constantly ask it hey are you ready to
run if why aren't you done yet and just
kind of annoy it and then but the nice
thing is once the data becomes available
for transformation and that complete
check passes we can launch the pipeline
right and it's completely automated so
let's just go through I'll go through
each stage not not code wise but I'll go
through kind of in English what each
done state is for each of those five
steps right we talked to have the
transform one already there's a lot of
Pandora hive tables a lot but we want to
narrow that down to just the spins that
we're interested in so we create our own
manage table my team for that
partitioned by day still but we do
certain things to their raw data like we
duplicate them they do some of that too
but we do our own deduplication just in
case we filter out certain properties of
songs like if it doesn't spin for longer
than 30 seconds the labels seem
uninterested in that maybe I could get
yelled at after this but I was told that
at least and then we have some other
joins we do to kind of
to kind of keep it sane we keep the same
partitioning structure we keep it by day
and then we do we do other things for
the metadata too so that way I described
that metadata and like listeners
stations it doesn't start that way we
have to kind of massage it down to that
very natural form how to denormalize it
so to speak so it's it's just easier to
build this data set form and then I most
noticeably like we just don't want to be
just seeing hundreds of tables to do it
on our side we'd rather take advantage
of their cluster and use we use hive on
tez it's very fast
to build out some of those partitions
and then we can just sync them back so
if it passes the Monroes checks we're
done we consider that valid for the
partitions we're actually considering
switching this out to just use snake
bite by level checks for sanity because
it's a little bit faster than having
actually issue a query even if it tez is
still like we don't really we could be
doing this in milliseconds with snake by
directory check bytes for the part files
we don't really need to issue a query so
you'd consider that if anyone was
thinking that and we might do that just
to make it better and then so once
that's done the disk C P stage is ready
to done we run in atomic disk CP nothing
really fancy we add it to the warehouse
and very obviously that stage is done if
the partitions exist in hive so we can
very easily build out that state and
then the generation stage kicks in we
use spark sequel for this so the legacy
report was kind of a high of M our job
and it was a natural transition just to
take a lot of that with a few minor
changes and just run that right as spark
sequel over hive within a hive session
they're all part K events so we get
pretty fast filtering just from that we
can filter when we're running the
generation now we're getting label
specific right so we give it the task is
gonna run with just a label and that
control that's fed to the Scala job in
terms of how we're going to filter it
down and we can actually do multiple
license or label reports and parallel
this way too and which is what we do so
and then as part of that spark sequel
thing all the metadata gets joined in
artists composers stations they want to
we want to create a sync for every
single spin we want to make it as rich
as possible
reported the labels for fields that
they've said they were interested in and
then the most important part is in the
driver directly we actually validate we
do an additional validation on the
number of rows that come out of that
stage and we have lower up and upper
bounds for this so it has to actually
fall within like an expected if there
were maybe issues of the metadata or
something like that even though we had
those defensive checks maybe still
something went wrong you can't be too
defensive so we check lower and upper
bound limits why do we do upper bound I
guess we actually did have one case
they're somehow new lines got introduced
into some of the fields and ever since
then we just like don't take any chances
why not but so if you want to throw off
the music industry's reporting you might
you could name your track or your band
character turn new line or something
they might not our reporting now so and
then we if this if it gets past this
stage we output multiple part files to
Hadoop to HDFS we still do a lot Colo
Khan Prem so we've run HDFS we don't we
don't actually do a lot of our
processing like in at s3 like that we
have bare-metal HDFS if anyone was
wondering I couldn't answer questions
about that later
for what I know so this is sort of what
this is part of the Scala job it's
really kind of uninteresting but it just
illustrates one point we run the the
hive query we run it as just raw sparks
equal text and that text gets
parameterize with string replace before
it gets sent to the session command and
we still call out of just habit like we
call persist memory and disk
even though cache as of spark 2 is just
the synonym for that if you look under
the hood we're so used to cache from
spark 1x days just calling storage level
memory and having to deal with that that
we we just still in this habit from our
our DD days but once we have that data
frame the results we can call count on
it feed it to the check row bounds
function and then that will actually
elevate an exception if it fails the
validation check and then the whole
pipeline heart fails and we get alerted
but if it doesn't if it passes it just
sort of silently returns and we can go
on to just saving those results to a
label on dates
specific HDFS location but the nice
thing too it's a really nice use of
spark it kind of illustrates the the
caching benefit because we can do a
validation step right and the spark
driver and because it's cached it
doesn't have to read materialize and
reevaluate everything - to do the save I
know this is spark 101 stuff but
sometimes the the benefits of the
caching aren't always obvious this is
tremendously Bennet and if it fails
validation there's nothing we have to
clean up right it's just an ephemeral
data frame just dies so then once all
these part files are written out
we need to coalesce them into a single
file some customers want compressed visa
others want gzip I'm not sure what which
one is the orchard of the check but we
have to handle both of those cases and
for bees if this is a little easier the
their output is already be zipped part
files and we can just binary cat those
together into a single file very
effortlessly with Hadoop copy merge and
then we get a single just a single B zip
file with there's even a nice flag to
just clean up the original files after
it's done
so if it succeeds atomically it deletes
those files as part of that action
I think atomically but then gzip is a
little bit more annoying but not too bad
we just have to write out uncompressed
files and they take up more space but we
can use copy merge on uncompressed files
and do the same thing wipe them out
after there's a single compressed file
and then just run that through gzip and
we get a single compressed file I put
this here because I didn't always
actually know I've been working with the
dupe for a while and I never even used
this this copy merge thing so there's
other people here that haven't used that
or didn't know about it it's really
handy and then the done state is this
predictably writing my guess we we
expect a single compressed file in HDFS
for the label and the date and if it's
there we're consider all ready
considered valid we validated all the
data at the part file level and the job
and we can operate off just that single
file the assumptions around that so the
s3 push stage kicks in and we just take
the single file put it up to a name the
labels all get their own individual
buckets right for Abby
reasons they don't want each others they
don't want to share their data with each
other it makes sense so they get their
own bucket and then we write out a new
path in that bucket for the for the
given date and then we can tell very
quickly if we're done with the s3 target
classes and the we'd you just is it
there or not so this is a short
presentation but just the takeaways of
this I guess if there's stuff to learn
out of this the we we built all this so
that it could be run very aggressively
from cron and it's a little confusing to
see daily tasks that operate with daily
granularity being run every ten minutes
and it does produce more logs and cabaña
and other things we have to deal with
finding the log that actually ran it can
be annoying but it's a small price to
pay for going to the self-healing aspect
and the automation that comes out of
just we don't even have to think about
how these are run if they fail it's
because there's a real issue with the
Pandora cluster or something or
something we did with like a patch that
we put in trying to make it better and
we've screwed up but we don't have to
guess when it's ready to run we just let
the code figure it out for us and we
just have cron try to just try over and
over again annoyingly and if there's an
issue it just picks up right at the at
the most natural Check Point where it
succeeded whoops so all of the tasks are
compiled I sound like a broken record I
guess but the tasks composition is
designed around these checkpoints right
we had to we had to think logically
about where I made sense to break these
off whereas the first iteration of the
pipeline didn't really do that it was it
would build the single-file wall it was
generating the report and that had
problems and it goes without saying like
the a lot of talked about about the
fault tolerance part of it because it's
less obvious but using the latest
frameworks kind of switching this over
to some of the latest using high montes
where we can and then spark where we
control it really helped for the parts
that we can control like using the
latest open source frameworks just
getting fast speed and execution so
there's any kind of issue with it
it doesn't take forever to run or
backfill we have to backfill more than
we would like but that's it are there
any questions about I didn't cover like
how it improved I know I made that a
professor
answer yeah just wondering he's not
using crown do you have some sort of
event cheaper that to trigger deadlines
we don't we could explore that that
would make it easier I guess that would
take the form of a task that was polling
the raw data but it's still it there's
less to be honest an inception point to
launch yeah I'd have to explore that
more maybe we certainly thought about
changing this from it's right now it's
kind of a poll model and it could be
more of a push but haven't explored that
that much it'll probably to be honest
with you but probably before that we'll
switch it out to will be accumulating
these directly off the kafka streams and
so the report that the datasets will be
generating throughout the day as spins
come in and then as soon as the day ends
we'll we'll be able to pipe it up yes
siree that's probably what will happen
first so we use them Luigi and basically
kick off the pie Spock job so I'm just
curious that you using a scholar Spock
essentially how does that sort of like
work in terms of calling you know you
know scholar Spock within some Luigi
because Luigi's in Python yeah so
there's in the Luigi contribute there is
a really nice spark submit task it's
actually Luigi could trib and I think
it's directly and like Luigi contribs
spark is the import spark submit task so
you can use that you it's really easy to
submit a scholar spark test it's a
little trickier we'd have PI spark tasks
as well it's just a little bit trickier
to use that I'll just say that the
contribute that they have like a PI
spark submit tasks that they've also
contributed and that's junk we don't we
don't use that but it's the the base one
that's been contributed makes it really
easy to do this so you just point it to
a jar and you give it the name of the
class in that jar and the Luigi tasks
only job is to make a spark to submit
command
and so you can actually see we print out
that command we see what it looks like
and it just runs
so using Luigi is just an easier way to
have not have to make a spark to submit
command by hand I think that's that's
all gains other questions for Brian you
mentioned you guys still use HDFS like
not relying on its third serenade reason
for not crossing the line were staying
where it is um there is I mean they've
been political reasons in the past we do
consider Amazon a competitor and there's
on people use Amazon music I don't
actually think those are the real
reasons and I can say that because we're
the next two years I think there's a
pretty aggressive plan to work out to go
into GCP the Google Cloud we're gonna
transition a lot to that and they are
still competitor there's Google music so
that thing I used to think that way for
a while and it's not that there's really
no I think it's just the the bare metal
we've always we've been kind of addicted
to the bare metal performance and we
have really great hops like sysadmin
people that are just really good with
Hadoop and it has if it got to be a
problem where we would we saw that is we
didn't have to worry about these issues
but we don't really have a lot of those
issues are a lot of our hiccups and come
from the application level like the data
engineers like myself right we screw up
something in however we made a patch to
the job that's producing all the
upstream raw data and that failed so so
you know I think it has to do with the
fact that they just haven't been big
woes
they haven't bitten us yet in ways that
have become huge time sinks
alright any other questions for Brian oh
we got one back here
I was just wondering what you like about
hive that you still keep it around
in addition like I know there's some
benefits but like what makes it worth it
to you to like support all that extra
infrastructure over just using spark for
everything yeah it's a good question I
know some of its outside not to defer
too much you know there's a lot of teams
at Penn where they wear heavy
Hortonworks users and Hortonworks has
gotten a lot behind hive in recent years
with ll AP and so if you live in the
whole Hortonworks environment you tend
to kind of go down the the pathways of
those tools we the the Pandora there's
there's all sorts of different the teams
and they're not that homogeneous in
terms of like this team uses hive only
and this there's there's all sorts of
different activity on these clusters and
spark hive on tez we have an Impala
cluster there's other warehouses so it's
like there's very few hive MapReduce
jobs left what I'll say it's we've what
we've gotten addicted to is kind of hive
is a catalog as the meta store the meta
store and hive is probably going to live
on way belong way past even many of
these frameworks that these execution
engines that are that are down in the
dirty with hive the meta stories just
will probably live on as a means of
cataloging it and so that's kind of what
Pandora has gotten addicted to but hive
itself in terms of the way we used to
think about it like when I contributed
to hive is it's totally different now
the people that use it in production how
I get like sub-second latency with hive
now because they're running they're
running press over the meta store and
Paulo Ortez or something and we're
sparks equal like we do so we it's just
not too much of a concern and we get
some nice properties out of it
you